there's a cloud looming over the future
of clean energy
it's called curtailment and it's the
biggest obstacle to weaning the world
off fossil fuels curtailment happens
when we actually produce too much wind
or solar power at certain times of the
day we have to just shut it down but
what if we sent that extra electricity
into giant batteries to use when the Sun
Goes Down or the wind stops blowing that
day just might be coming sooner than you
think the easiest way to curtail
curtailment would be a massive explosion
of energy storage
ideally batteries there's just one
problem
batteries are still way too expensive
take a place like Texas a quarter of the
electricity from the Lone Star State
comes from wind when the wind dies down
texans just fire up a natural gas power
plant to make up the difference
battery prices would have to drop by
half in order to compete with those
texts and natural gas plants today less
than 1/10 of 1% of the world's
electricity spends any time in a storage
battery and even by 2040 the best
forecasts say that batteries will make
up just 3% of the world's power supply
but consider the experience curve
renewable energy is a technology not a
fuel so prices follow what economists
call an experience curve the more solar
panels we make the better we get at
making them in fact every time the
number of panels in the world doubles
the cost to make them drops by 28%
solar-powered just recently became the
cheapest electricity in the world and
it's only going to get cheaper and it
turns out the same thing is happening
with batteries as we build more with
electric cars and electricity storage
the cost of batteries plummets it's
already dropped 80% in the last day
and could do the same in the next boom
at those prices battery storage in a
place like Texas suddenly becomes a
no-brainer we're already starting to see
it happen in places where the
electricity is expensive in Hawaii the
rainforest island of Kauai swapped its
fossil fuel power for solar plus
batteries and Tesla has made deals in
California and Australia to install the
world's biggest battery fields the
battery Behrend Elon Musk says his newly
built massively populated Giga factory
will spit out batteries faster than
bullets from a machine gun it will
single-handedly double the global supply
and he wants to start building at least
two more Giga factories in 2018 but musk
is in for an arms race Chinese companies
say they'll build capacity for about
three Giga factories worth of batteries
by 2021 Samsung LG Chem and others are
also joining the fray now this is not a
done deal if the battery revolution is
going to work tens of millions of people
must switch to electric cars over the
next decade to feed the experience curve
but there are also new technologies
coming soon like the silicone anodes
solid-state batteries and lithium air
that could skip us ahead on the
experience curve by more than a decade
making battery-powered trains ships and
even airplanes possible so imagine a
world where City skies are clear of
pollution and where electricity is cheap
and abundant it's not crazy to assume
that 20 years from now over half the
world's power will come from nature
backed by batteries and it all might be
happening sooner than you think
[Music]
you